[Music]
you forget I love it Axl's taking
hip-hop lessons can we see a mother-son
dance off how are his moves well he's
taking hip-hop dance class that's called
hey I think I think he would just be
better off probably getting lessons from
DJ Khaled Diddy he wants to get hip hop
across the board it's a blessing to be
able to embrace all forms of music and
with Axl you never know whether he's
gonna be singing crazy frog or you know
dancing - dj khaled or Diddy or whomever
some of the lyrics that mom used to
listen to anyway but now I realize
they're inappropriate but I didn't
really know before I had a kid who could
understand them so yeah it's about Bracy
embracing everything and yeah his he did
his little hip hop dance recital on
Mother's Day and I was super cute and he
did a great job and I'm super proud
mommy that proud mama is ready to get to
work
on season two of the four meanwhile her
co-stars Diddy and DJ Khaled are looking
forward to another extra special day
this month I just want to say happy
early Father's Day to Diddy and Khalid
thank you guys celebrating do they do it
yeah I'm not involved with something
better be doing some exciting you say
it's my second year being a father
yeah almost excited every day is
Mother's Day by the way every day
hopefully no mama Assad and Assad good
about it great laughs fun yeah - is a
very important it's gonna be a special
yeah
thank you happy father's day my brother
yeah yeah
make sure I make sure you're tuned in to
the for Fox Thursday 8:00 p.m. this
Thursday this Thursday 8:00 p.m.
we're gonna take it up a notch another
one tune in and turn up
[Music]